يلا
كده جديد بقى
اوكي
تمام
اعتقد
انا على الهواء كده
طيب مزبوط
مساء الخيرات للمره التانيه سامحونا لسبب
لا نعلمه يعني خلل في يوتيوب ولا خلل
عندنا في الكناكشن يعني قطعت علينا الحلقه
الاولانيه وعليكم السلام يا ابراهيم
وعليكم السلام وعليكم السلام حمزه انا
الحقيقه كنت على وشك ان اختم قبل القطع
فانا حابب برضو انه انا لا اطيل عليكم
اكثر من ذلك احنا بس يعني لو كان عليكم
السلام ورحمه الله حسن العمري
شكرا لقناتك ده اخونا خليفه والردود ذات
الرقيه حتى مع من يختلفون معك وانا من
متابعيك بشغف وان اختلفت معك احيانا لانك
فرضت نفسك سؤالي الى اي حد تاثرت تؤثر
التسريبات على العلاقات الدول
خليفه من الدول انا الحقيقه كنت يعني اوكي
انا اسمحولي كمان
ونختم
لا التاثير هيكون كبير يا خليفه تاثير
التسريبات كبير
لا هيكون في طبعا تاثيرات كبيره
على علاقه الدول اللي موست
النواه اللي فضحت هتطال دول كثيره يعني
ربنا يخليك عليكم السلام شكرا جزيلا احمد
منور ربنا يخليك احبك في الله ربنا يخليك
السلام عليكم استاذ سيد ربنا يخليك شكرا
لقناتك اوكي منور ربنا اجبت عليك يا استاذ
خليفه طبعا لو علق عندك سؤال محدد عن دوله
معينه بكل سرور يعني
يعني انا عشان سؤال خليفه ممكن يتكرر على
لسانه ناس كثيره
تاثير
الليكس هيختلف من دوله للتانيه يعني لما
دوله زيي مثلا دوله زي اسرائيل لما تكشف
ان هي على سبيل المثال بتنوي ان هي تمد
اوكرانيا
باسلحه او دوله زي مصر تيجي وثيقه تقول ان
هي بتمد روسيا باسلحه الدول ديت اما تتمسك
بمواقفها اللي هي كشفت عنها او تمسك
بمواقفها المعلنه وتلتزم بها دوله زي
كوريا الشماليه لما امريكا تقول والله ان
انت استعرضت فيه منتصف فبراير انظمه اطلاق
صواريخ وان جزء منها اصلا عاطل لا يعمل
وان انت استعرضت لهذه الصواريخ هي مش
تقدير المخابرات الامريكيه ان ارادت اظهار
انها اقوى مما هي عليه اكيد كوريا
الشماليه هتغير هذه الخدعه في المستقبل
بلد زي كوريا الجنوبيه اللي هما عندهم كان
من مخططهم انه يساعدوا كانوا مترددين
يساعدوا روسيا
فيغضبوها ويستجيبوا لضغوط الولايات
المتحده ولا لا ويحتفظوا بموقفهم المحايد
لما يعلن ان هم ارادوا التحايل على هذا
الموقف باعطاء ذخيره لبولندا وبولندا
تديها الاوكرانيا لما يكشف هذا الموقف هل
هتستمر كوريا الجنوبيه في هذا المخطط ولا
تلتزم بموقفها المعلن وعليه
فالوثائق هتغير كثير من حسابات الدول
زياد منور يا استاذي كل سنه وانت طيب الله
يحفظك نحن سعداء بالاطلال الله يحفظك خالد
ربنا يخليك مراد شكرا جزيلا
هل عندك معلومات عن ثروات سوريا الطبيعيه
غير التي ذكرها النظام السوري على الاقل
ليست حاضره الان في ذهنه يعني لكنها ليست
سرا اذا كان عن البلد عندها
[موسيقى]
يعني اي ريزورف من الغاز الطبيعه والبترول
ما بيكونش السر الدول عارفاه الى حد كبير
بس مش لازم تكون البلد غنيه عشان تبقى
مهمه سوريا هي مهمه من غير ثروات طبيعيه
هل ما زال هناك وقت للاسئله يعني احنا
قدامنا كمان خمس دقايق انا تحت امرك هذا
هو الجزء الثاني السلام عليكم تحياتي هل
يمكن للصين ان تدخل وسيطا في المنطقه خاصه
في القضيه الفلسطينيه وبعد نجاح المبادره
بين ايران والسعوديه كل شيء ممكن اما وقد
حدث الشيء الصعب جدا جدا جدا انه صعب ده
حاجتين الصين تقليديا كانت بتقول استفيد
تجاريا
وازيح عن راسي كل الصداع السياسي في الشرق
الاوسط وما اكثره بدا هذا يتغير وبدات
تدخل وسيطا في
الصراعات الشائكه واخترت صراعا بالغ
الحساسيه وهو الصراع الايراني السعودي
الامر الثاني ان هذا بدا يؤتي ثماره وبدات
تبقى في انفراجه ولو مؤقته اتمنى ان هي
تستمر فممكن تدخل وسيدا في صراعات اخرى
ربما لا يكون الصراع الفلسطيني لانه لا
يمثل اولويه لا للامريكان ولا للصينيين
ولا الاسرائيليين ولا للعرب انا اسف ان
انا بقول كده ولكن هذا ما اراه لكن في
صراعات اخرى ممكن تدخل فيها
عاجل عوده العلاقات
عاجل عوده العلاقات الدبلوماسيه بين سوريا
والسعوديه وانا بقى لي ساعتين يبقى ده ده
جيد جدا ويستحق ان احنا نتكلم عنه
بالتفصيل ان شاء الله في اقرب فرصه انت
بتبشر بتزف الينا خبر مؤثر ومهم السلام
عليكم ارجو الرد ما رايك باحداث 11 سبتمبر
وهل هي فعلا مؤامره من المخابرات اذا كانت
مؤامره هتبقى حاجه سريه لا اعلم عنها شيئا
الله اعلم فعلا اتمنى اعرف بس عشان تعرف
محتاج تقضي السنين من عمرك
لازم الوثائق تكشف لنا بقى بعد 30/35 سنه
من الحارث وتقول لنا خبايا لا نعلمها
عاجل عوده العلاقات تعلمنا بالخبر منك على
عهدتك انها عادت هي كنا بنتوقع ان هي هم
كانوا كانوا كان وزير الخارجيه النهارده
السوري فيه
الرياض وكنا من المتوقعين ان هم هيشاركوا
الشهر المقبل انا كنت لسه بقول في الجزء
الاولاني
مصر الى اين لو سمحت احنا اتكلمنا عن مصر
كثيرا نحن سعداء بالاطلال الله يخليك ما
شاء الله الاسئله كتير
ماذا عن الجزائر ماذا عن انا سمعت يا مراد
قل لي ماذا عن الجزائر في ايه انا تحت
امرك لو اعرف اقول بس عن الجزائر في ايه
الجزائر دوله كبيره وعندها داخله في ملفات
كثيره جدا عن اي ملف فيهم تتحدث سيد قبيل
المحترم اعاده الاعمار في سوريا مثلا لو
حصل من سيدفع هذه الاموال وعلى اي اساس
سيدفعون الدول اللي بتعمل اعاده اعمار
عندها نموذجين تقريبا ما اعرفش النموذج
الثالث النموذج الاولاني ان عندها ثروات
طبيعيه ما عندهاش فلوس حاضره يعني عندها
ثروات طبيعيه بترول غاز نحاس الدول بتخش
تعمر بتبقى ضامنه فلوسها من عوائد بيع هذه
السلعه الدوله هتبيع السلعه ديت البترول
والغاز وهتدفع للدول التي سوف تعمرها
الامر الثاني ما عندهاش فلوس ما عندهاش
ثروات طبيعيه
فبتدخل الشركات
وبتستحوذ على اصول في الدوله مثلا هبني لك
ميناء وهاخد حق اداره الميناء ده لعشرين
ثلاثين سنه وانت كدوله استفدت من عندك
ميناء وسوف تستفيد منه بعد ان تنتهي الحق
الاداره والمنفعه بعد عشرين ثلاثين سنه او
تدير
[موسيقى]
يعني تعطي بقى مساعدات وكذا في مقابل
مصالح تاخد قاعده عسكريه مثلا بس
النموذجين الاولانيين هم اللي هم الكبار
يعني الاساسيين
السلام عليكم ما رايك بالايام القادمه
بالنسبه للدول العربيه انا في تقديري انا
عملت حلقه دقيقه ويا ريت تقولي لي اذا كنت
قاعدها في حلقه كبيره انه احنا بنعيش فتره
ديطان والدي طنط هي الكلمه الفرنسيه
المستخدمه في العلاقات الدوليه التي تعني
فتره انفراجه والانفراجه تعني ان الدول
بدات تتخلى عن الاساليب الخشنه وتمد يدها
بالسلام الاجابه المختصره جدا لغايه ما
نتكلم عنها اذا اردتم ان احنا نتعاولها
هنتناولتها في شورت باقتراح من ماندو 53
ثانيه محدش شافها غير 16 17 الف يعني
ممكن نعملها حلقه يعني
لكن اجابه مختصره جدا انه
كان مختصرا ان هم لجاوا الى هذا الاسلوب
لان هم يئسوا من فكره فرض راي كل واحد على
الاخر بالقوه العسكريه
بس يا ريت تقولوا لي اعيد الحلقه ديت في
حلقه كبيره ولا لا ولا هيبقى شكل قررت
العنوان ولا ايه يعني
تحياتي لك كيف كيف تحدث التسريبات في دول
كل الولايات المتحده
لغز كبير هو حاجه من الاتنين اما عندك
صراعات داخل الولايات المتحده هذه
الصراعات بتبقى صراع قوى واحد عندك دول
كتيره برضو مستقره بيحصل فيها صراعات واحد
الاطراف المتصارعه الجمهورين ضد
الديمقراطيين جماعه واحد بيعبر عن جماعه
يعني شارده عن المنستريم قرر انه يفضح
بلده اللي هو شايفها انا دوله معتديه زي
ما حصل كده في قصص مختلفه
الان موجود في روسيا
او دوله بتعمل حاكم
فيها تقصير في لحظه تقصير حصل فيها ذلك
فين بقى السيناريو تاني خالص ان الولايات
المتحده وده السيناريو مش غريب تتعمد
عمليه التسريب لهدف في ذهنها وكل ديه
سيناريوهات مطروحه لا احد يستطيع ان يجزم
بها كل ما نستطيع ان نجزم به انه جزء من
هذه الوثائق على وجه اليقين صحيح وجزء
ثاني محل شك والذي نستطيع ان نجذب ان هذه
التسريبات سوف يكون لها تاثيرات ليست
قليله في الفتره المقبله لانها اربكت
حسابات دول كثيره كانت تجري حساباتها على
انها سر وفجاه فضح ما كانت تدبر له
ما هو رايك في الوضع السياسي والاقتصادي
في تونس وضع ماذون جدا جدا جدا ولن يكون
هناك من قال لتونس الا بانه هي تستطيع ان
تحصل على دعم الدول من خارج صندوق من خارج
صندوق النقد السلام عليكم استاذ سيد هل تم
تسريب الوثائق عمدا من الولايات المتحده
لسه كنت بقول
اخونا
على انه ده احد السيناريوهات المحتمله لكن
لا استطيع ان اجزم بذلك تحياتي هل هناك
امل في انفصال جنوب اليمن انت بتعتبره
وامل واخرين بيعتبروه هيكون امر مدرب
اليمنيين لكن اعتقد ان ده اصبح امر واقع
على الارض الان ولازم الجنوب علشان ينضم
الى الشمال لازم يكون عنده اغراءات كبيره
جدا او العكس في الحاله في الوضع الراهن
فينا الوضع الراهن الان اللي استات سكول
الوضع الراهن ان احنا امام دولتين في
اليمن الخوف كل الوقوف ان الجنوب بدل ما
يبقى دوله يبقى عده دول طب وليه الخوف كل
الخوف لانه هيبقى متحاربين فيما بين هم
ما
كيف تقرا العلاقات بين دول الشرق الاوسط
كان بينهما اعداء مثل سوريا وايران واليمن
لسه كنت بقول انه احنا بنعيش فتره ديطانت
اللي هي كلمه بالمناسبه كلمه اصطلح عليها
لما لما الاتحاد السوفيتي والغرب بداوا
يخففوا من التوتر لفتره مؤقته اظن من 67
68 ل 79 يعني
فاحنا بنعيش هذه الفتره اتمنى ان هي تطول
وتثمر ولان الكل خسر من المواجهات
العسكريه والاقتصاديه والحروب بالوكاله
والحروب المباشره لماذا لا ترغب الاردن
باستخراج مواردها خاصه ان لديها معادن
وحقول نفط هل يمكن ان يتم منع ذلك من
الدول ما اعرفش في حاله اليمن في حاله
الاردن ان هي منعت من دول اخرى وما عرفش
ان عندها ثروات وهي ممتنعه عن استثمارها
لكن اعرف ان في دول بتمنع فعلا من استثمار
ثرواتها لان في دول عندها دول كبيره عندها
مخططات او
بلانز لهذه الدوله
معرفش في وضع الاردن لكن كمبدا عام يمكن
ان تولع دول تمنع دول كبيره الدول الاصغر
من الاستفاده بثروتها في توقيت ما
هل تتوقع حدوث حرب عالميه العالم كله
بيتوقع الان يا حمزه مش انا بس
مستقبل الدولار في اطار اخبار البريكس
احنا اتكلمنا فيه عن البريكس في الحلقه
الجزء الاولاني قبل ان يقطع علينا البث
بالتفصيل لكن اللي انا اقدر اقوله لك انه
الدولار سوف يظل عمله مهيمنه ورئيسه من
المؤشرات لفتره طويله وفي نفس الوقت نفوذه
او حصته في التجاره الدوليه بتتراجع بشكل
قليل ولكن منتظم اسلوب المؤشرات بتقول كده
ما ماذا بعد ابو مازن عباس ماذا بعد ابو
مازن عباس الله يدي له الصحه والعافيه
الفلسطينيين عندهم كوادر كثيره وما كانش
يعني لن يتوقفوا على طبعا الله يدي له
الصحه والعافيه عندهم كوادر كثيره يمكن ان
تخلفه استاذي الكريم هل من الممكن سقوط
امريكا عن التطبيع مع الاسد دون اي عواقب
لا ممكن يبقى في عواقب بس المشكله ان
امريكا مش عارفه حل يعني لا هي عارفه لا
هي قادره تتخلص من بشار الاسد ولا هي جاده
في التخلص منه ولا هي راغبه في التعامل
معه فهي مرتبكه وعامله ربكه للعالم كله
هل الدول العربيه بحاجه الى قائد ولماذا
لا يتحدون لا يتحدون مع تركيا يحلوا
مشاكلهم اول مع تركيا اخونا الكريم ده هم
عندهم مشاكل بيجاهدوا لحلها بعد سنوات
اللي حاول التركيه انها تفرض رؤيتها على
الشرق الاوسط من 2010 الى الان الاتحاد
بالصوره اللي انت بتتكلم عليها ديت شيء من
الماضي الاتحاد الاوروبي نفسه مهدد
بالتفكك انما يتفاهم مع بعض يقللوا
خلافتهم زي ما بيحاولوا يعملوا دلوقتي
استاذنكم في السؤال الاخير هل تتفق معي ان
الوثائق المسربه
وما كشفته من اختراق الاجهزه
الروسيه كانت السبب بتحكيم الاداره
الروسيه لدور الجيش او الاعتماد بدلا عنها
نهى انا مش فاهم السؤال سؤال هل تتفق معي
ان الوثائق المسربه وما كشفته من اختراق
السي اي اي للاجهزه الروسيه كانت السبب
بتحجيم الاداره الروسيه لدور الجيش
والاعتماد بدلا ذلك على اه بس فهمت
هرجع تاني ان هو واضح لو كانت الوثائق
دقيقه يبقى واضح ان تم اختراق لكثير من
الاجهزه الروسيه هي دي مش مفاجئ اكيد
الاجهزه الامريكيه مخترقه الاجازه الروسيه
واكيد روسيا مخترقه اجهزه امريكيه لكن لو
كانت الوثائق سليمه يبقى حجم الاختراق
الامريكي للاجهزه الروسيه ضخم جدا وحتى لو
ما فيش هذا الحجم من الاختراق واحد من اهم
ما اظهرتوا هذه الحرب ان امريكا لديها
قدرات استخباراتيه
متفوقه جدا على كل دول العالم متفوقه جدا
على الروز بحيث ان هي بامكانيات
الاستخباراتيه بتقول للجيش الاوكراني
بتكشف له تحركات الجيش الروسي
وخططه اهد هدف مسبقا ودي قصه
ده الظاهر حتى الان من المؤشرات هنتبينوا
ان طيب مع الوقت التفوق الكاسح
القدرات الاستخباراتيه الامريكيه مديها
كبير جدا على خصومها او على الاقل بالنسبه
لروسيا في الحاله اللي احنا بنتكلم عليها
السلام عليكم عليكم السلام ما هي البقيه
الحقيقيه
ما هي القيمه الحقيقيه للتنميه المصريه
للمشاريع المصريه في عهد السيسي وهل تستحق
الهلا الاعلاميه والله الراجل عمل في
المشاريع ضخمه جدا بعضها يستحق الثناء وفي
مشروعات تانيه محل جدال ويمكن ان توصف
بانها وايت او انها يمكن كان يمكن ان تؤجل
لاولويات اخرى والسؤال ده مطروح منذ 2015
منذ ان بدا الرجل المشاريعه وهي محل خلاف
هنحتاج وقت لتقييم المشروعات ديت بعد ان
تجلس صوره بوضوح جدا وتتبين لنا كل
الارقام لكن ما في شك انه الان
الاسئله دي بتثور بشده بسبب الازمه
الاقتصاديه اللي بتمر بيها مصر استاذي
الكريم هل على فكره في حلقه بعنوان
الافيال البيضاء ممكن ترجعوا لها حلقه
قديمه كانت بتتكلم على المشروعات القوميه
في مصر استاذي الكريم هل ممكن ده يكون
السؤال الاخير ممكن يا ماندو هل الدول نعم
[موسيقى]
عندنا اسئله كثيره لسه
استاذي الكريم هل ممكن هل يمكن ان تجر
اسرائيل العالم
الى حرب مع ايران ومع من تتوقع الاطراف
التي سوف تقف معها جمال
هي ممكن اه ممكن
يعني التاريخ بيقول لنا
ما رايك في الغواصه النوويه التي ارسلتها
الولايات المتحده للبحرين لا اعلم عنها
شيئا هل الناتج المحلي هو ارباح الدوله ام
الشعب المجتمع كله افراد شركات حكومه
التلات قطاعات دول هم اللي بيمثلوا اقتصاد
اي دوله
وناتج
والقيمه النقديه لكل نشاطاتهم الاقتصاديه
من سلع وخدمات خلال عام كامل يعني
بتشوف كل اللي تم انتاجه في الدوله من كل
القطاعات من كل البشر سواء البشر ده
بينتبه للحكومه او فرد دكتور مدرس او شركه
عامه خاصه كل اللي انتجوه من سلع يعني
[موسيقى]
موبايلات
اي حاجه زجاج تكييف اي حاجه وخدمات زي
تعليم صحه سياحه وبتحسب القيمه النقديه له
بكام بالعمله المحليه وبتقول كل انتاج
البلد ده في السنه ديت
بيساوي مليار وممكن بعد كده تحوله للدولار
او غيره ولو عاوز طريقه الحزبه بدقه ادخل
على نعرف اقتصاد وهتشوف الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي كيف يحسب بدقه شديده مع اخونا
وصديق العزيز الاقتصاد المحترم هاني جنينه
هل ايران محمد العتيمي هل ايران راح تتخلى
تتخلى مشروعها التوسعي بعد صرف عشرات
المليارات
وحرمان شعبها من التنميه 40 سنه هل تتخلى
عن ذلك بكل سهوله ما فيش حد لا ايرانها
تتخلى عن تضحيتها بكل سهوله ولا السعوديه
ولا دول الخليج هيثقوا في ايران بسهوله
ولا العداء ولا الخلافات هتنتهي بمجرد انه
يعني حصل تطبيع ولكن اللي حصل مؤخرا ان كل
الدول ادركت ان المواجهه مكلفه للكل
فتعالوا ندير خلافتنا مش ان احنا ننساها
في فرق بين ان انت تحل الخلاف تماما ده
صعب لان في خلافات ما بتتحلش ان احنا نرجع
الثقه كامله صعب محتاج سنين لكن في حاجه
اسمه اداره الخلافات الامثله على ده في
حلقه اسمها الاصدقاء الاعداء استاذنكم او
يعني فيها كلمه الاصدقاء الاعداء ممكن
تشوفوها اللي هو خلاصتها كده ان في دول
بتقول ايه انا عندي خلاف مع دوله
فخلينا نتعاون فيما يمكن ان نتعاون فيه
وليعذر بعضنا بعضا فيما نختلف عليه بمعنى
انه ممكن دوله تبقى عارفه ان الدوله دي
بتضرب مصالحها في افريقيا لكن بتتعاون
معها في اسيا
التبادل التجاري عظيم جدا لكن الدولتين
بيحاربوا بعض في دوله تانيه والدنيا بتمشي
بالشكل ده يعني بلاش نخلي المساله
هم مثلا السعوديه وايران زي مثلا
هيتصارعوا في زي مثلا في سوريا او
هيتصارعوا في لبنان لكن ممكن يتعاونوا في
اليمن ممكن يتفقوا على خطوط حمراء ما
نتجاوزهاش انه ايران تعزز الجامعات اللي
هي بتدعمها في كل الدول ديت بس الجامعات
دي تبقى محجمه لا تهاجم المصالح السعوديه
وهكذا يعني
مش هتبقى حاجه غريبه الدول كلها بتعمل كده
وسوريا ومثلا بلد زي فرنسا والمانيا
وبريطانيا هي دول اوروبيه عن امثله هائله
على الخلافات في ملفات والتعاون في ملفات
تانيه طبعا تركيا وروسيا مثال رائع جدا
اتخانق في ملفات ونتعاون في ملفات
قبيل اتمنى تكون منصف حينما تقول القرن
كفلسطين لروسيا وانت تعلم
انهم محتلينها من سكانها الاصليين بلغار
الفولجا او تطاير القرم والذين قتلوهم
وهجروهم من القرم
وصيبيريا وشمال البحر الاسود بالمناسبه يا
صديقي اللي قال ان القرن كفلسطين لروسيا
مش سيد جبيل ده القالها الروس كانوا
بيحاولوا يقربوا الصوره وبيقولوا انه
القرم ارضا مقدسه لنا مثل القدس لليهود او
القدس للعرب للتعبير بتاع
السياسيين الروس مش انا اللي عملته يعني
وانا ما ليش مصلحه في ان انا دافع على ان
الروسي يحتلوا القرم او لا يحتلوها يعني
لا خالص انا بقول لك وجهه نظر الروس وجهه
نظر الاوكران وجهه نظر الامريكان واللي
بيشتغل في العلاقات الدوليه صعب ان هو
يكون له موقف عاطفي من كل قضيه انا بحلل
ازاي مثلا الخلاف الجزائري المغربي بقول
لك المغرب وجهه نظرها كده الجزائر وجهه
نظرها هكذا مش مطلوب حاجتين ان يكون ليا
موقف عاطفي من كل قضايا لان القضايا كثيره
جدا ومش مطلوب ان انا احسم الراي في قضيه
اخرى والا اكون شخص مقفول العقل يعني انا
النهارده اجي اقول انه المغرب على الحق
فيه قريه الصحراء الجزائر على حق معنى ذلك
ان انا بجزم بان انا على الهدايا كل
الوثائق وكل التاريخ واطلعت عليه وبقول
هذا صواب هذا خطا اولا ده مش متوفر وحتى
لو متوفر القضيه دي بتبقى مش بلاكن وايت
مش ابيض واسود قضايا متنازع عليها كل واحد
عنده وجهه نظر واللي بيتم حسمها اما
بالتفاوض والتراضي او
او طرف بيحسمها بالقوه العسكريه زي ما
الروس حسموها مع اوكرانيا
لماذا يا سيد جبيل
العلمانيه حلت لدول العربيه
مش ممكن تحكم الدول العربيه نظام اسلامي
معتدل لا مش ممكن يا صديقي احمد انا فهمت
سؤالك ليه بتعتقد انا بعتقد ان العلمانيه
الحلل الدول العربيه انا بقول العلمانيه
هي الحل لان العلمانيه بتعريفي انا ان
الدوله تقف على مسافه واحده من كل الاديان
وتسمح للمسلمين تؤمن مصالحها وتؤمن
عقائدهم وعبادتهم ما تسمح لهم الى
المسيحيين واليهود لانه لو الدول العربيه
عملت غير كده هتلاقي المشكله بلد زي
اسرائيل بتقول لك انا دوله اليهود لن اسمح
للعرب ولا المسلمين بممارسه حقوقهم وده لب
المشكله اللي هي موجوده الان في اسرائيل
هتلاقي بلد زي الهند بتقول لك الهند
للهندوس ولن اسمح للمسلمين وسوف اهدم
مساجدهم الى اخره بص للعالم كله الاغلبيه
من المسلمين يعيشون خارج الدول ذات
الاغلبيه المسلمه في 250 مليون مسلم في
الهند بس
اللي الاغلبيه فيها حوالي 900 مليون واكثر
للهندوس فالعلمانيه حل عام شامل يتجاوز
فكره ان في اغلبيه مسلمه في دوله
وهذا وجهه نظري بس تكون علمانيه بتقوم على
فكره انه بتحمي كل الاديان وكل المعتقدات
وبتضع ضوابط جيده جدا بس العلمانيه مساله
صعبه عاوزه مجتمعه متطور عاوزه ديمقراطيه
وعاوزه حريات وعاوزه حاجات كتيره وعاوز
انسي يدركوا انه تصورك انت كمسلم في ان
انا لازم احكم بشرعتي على الاخرين وتلاقي
نفسك الاخرين دول يعني الاديان الاخرى
فتوهمشهم بس تطالب بالعداله في دول اخرى
مش هيبقى موجود وبعدين انا احكم بشارات
يعني انا مسلم يعني انا سني شيعي اي مذهب
في السنه اي مذهب اللي بيتكلم بالدين
هيدخل في متاهات كثيره لن تمكنوا من بناء
دوله حديثه وانظر الى نموذج طالبان ودي
قصه طرحناه قبل كده
وانا احب ان انا اطرحها مره تانيه بكل
سرور اذا اردتم
بس يا ريت اللي يسمعها يسمعها بعقل مفتوح
مش بعقل بيدور على حاجه للرد بس طبعا لازم
ترد بس تسمع الاول بعقل مفتوح المنطق ما
هو الحل كيف يمكن ان يعيش مسلم في الهند
او في اسرائيل او في الصين اذا طبق نفس
المنطق
السلام عليكم استاذنكم السؤال الاخير ارجو
عمل حلقه عن مستقبل الاقتصاد في البلدان
النفطيه عموما والعراق بشكل خاص نتمنى
والله ربنا يمكننا من ذلك
هل صراع الصين مع امريكا في تايوان له
علاقه
او قد يؤثر سلبا او ايجابا على العلاقه
بين الصين وروسيا طبعا طبعا
لانه في الحاله ديت اعمل عمليه الغزو دي
امتى يعني
فكره انه تايوان تبقى جزء من الصين معناها
ان هيكون في صراع كبير الصراع الكبير ده
لازم يحدد لازم روسيا تاخد منها تاخد منه
موقف وبالتالي قد يعدد العلاقات مع الصين
وممكن في اللحظه لا يتخذ ما انت مش عارف
في انهي فتره ممكن الكلام يكون دلوقتي
ممكن يكون بعد عشر سنوات وتلاقي روسيا
عندها مخاوف من النصين تصبح قوه
اقوى بكثير مما تتمنى روسيا فتفضل لا انها
تضعفها تعرقلها
انا قلت ده اخر سؤال كتير بس عشان انا
محرج من الاصدقاء يعني بس ده اخر سؤال ان
شاء الله هل انتهت فتره السلام الامريكي
الباكس امريكان طبعا انتهت فتره البكس
امريكان اللي هي معناها ان امريكا عامله
زي يعني هي القوه المهيمنه الوحيده على
العالم ما هي اصبحت دوله كبيره عظمى لكنها
ما فيش فتره البكس امريكا
تحل كل مشاكل العالم بقرار من واشنطن انا
اسف جدا للاصدقاء ولكن احنا بقى لنا حوالي
ساعتين
فسامحوني انا شاكر جدا ليكم بعتذر على
القطع في البث اللي هو احنا مش عارفين
اسبابه اذا كان من عندنا من الانترنت او
من يوتيوب بعتذر للاصدقاء اللي لسه
داخلينه عندهم اسئله احنا بادئين من تسعه
ونص
واكرر شكري وتقديري لكم وربنا يسعد لنا
شكرا جزيلا جزيلا القاكم في المره القادمه
باذن الله